hi I'm Fermi okay
welcome to the stream this Ramadan
Muslims around the world have been asked
to stay at home Ramadan at home is a
hashtag and also a campaign asking
Muslims who observing Ramadan to stay
socially distant because of the corona
virus pandemic but how is that going to
work does it work you can tell us don't
by jumping into our YouTube chat we'd
love to bring your experiences into
today's show but let me introduce our
guests
Ramadan Kareem everybody's so good to
have you here
Robina welcome hello everybody who you
are thank you well done Mubarak to you
all my name is Ravina Khan I'm an
elected member in London accounts last
special advisor and the House of Lords
to the Liberal Democrat and I write
often for the independent get to have
you hello Rueda introduce yourself hello
everyone I'm Gideon
my name is it allows ease I am a
reporter at The Huffington Post based in
New York City where I cover Osama phobia
social justice issues and the like on a
national level great to have you and
finally Joseph welcome to the stream
tell everyone who you are I'm Joseph
Lombard I'm a professor of Quranic
studies at the College of Islamic
Studies at Hamad bin Khalifa University
in Doha and one of the contributing
editors and authors for the study of
Quran get to have you welcome everybody
let's start with this an idea there's so
much preparation that goes into Ramadan
but the idea of observing it during a
lockdown what is that even like Robina
you start what if your preparations been
like my preparations particularly as a
mother and as the working mother has
been very different so it was a mother
preparing the household under lockdown
making sure that our immune system and
boost it we've good product and making
sure that we're eating healthy as well
I'm
because I live in the house I have a
garden as well but I often have to
support people who live in cramped
conditions while overcrowded who will
finding it very difficult to home-school
so preparing constituents making sure
that they've got access to support in
terms of supporting their own families
and also working with charities on a to
aid programs to reach wonderful and
elderly people not just and very
isolated and so for me when I found in
preparing for my bond the most important
aspect is that we shouldn't again at a
time of Ramadan is not just thinking
about our thoughts but also about other
people and reflections so in terms of
reaching out to people and making sure
that those who might be lonely and maybe
feeling isolated we don't forget them as
well you know I'm just looking a tweet
that you said a few days ago and you
were talking about getting ready with
your children your nephews and nieces
preparing for Ramadan mas will be closed
prayers streamlined and if not
gatherings go digital we can find ways
to be together Joseph this idea of a
digital Ramadan what does that mean what
have you seen and what are you doing a
lot of people who embrace Islam later in
life have is they often don't feel as
embraced by the community and and so
it's funny there was actually a meme
that somebody was running that said that
it was one person was like there's a
born Muslim he's like oh my god
Ramadan without going to the mosques
everyday and out without gathering for
the family for iftar and the other guys
first time this is a regular experience
it's we're gonna come back to Joseph
he's got those slightly challenging
internet connection but we will come
back to him there's a tweet that Joseph
did swear though did share I'm gonna
share this with you as well and it's
about what you call iftar which is the
way that you break the fast at the end
of your fasting day and on this tweet
this is what Joseph shared so what can
we call iftar by zoom zip da or if you
do
that was my white street just just in
time what is it like how do you even do
iftar bye-bye
zoom we're way to jump in here yeah I
think at least here in the US we see in
this creation what we've dumped tears
ii-if stars I think that's the
terminology that we're going for and
it's this concept of trying to write
instead of breaking your fast at the end
of a beautiful meal with so many of your
family members relatives well there was
that Homer at a mosque or a dinner party
but people are gonna do it online and so
we use zooms and Google Hangouts and
Skype for work all day let's use it to
connect and I think to kind of jump on
Joseph's point I was talking to one
woman who reported that I was doing not
too long ago who had embraced Islam
later in life and she had heavily relied
on those communities to kind of help her
feel that spirit of Ramadan and she was
worried about the loneliness that she
was going to have to go through this
month and so one of the ways that she's
going to combat it is to set up a gift
ours iftar whatever we want to call it
every night with different runs and
families and I think it's a way to kind
of feel a little bit of community during
a time where were physically apart and I
am going to say as somebody who shares
an office with many wonderful Muslims
who observe Ramadan obviously socially
distant now of course one of the things
I found every Ramadan people do is that
they're sharing pictures of gorgeous
food that they're salivating over that
they can't eat quite yet but then they
go eat later so in that tradition I'm
going to show Rubina's iftar a big gift
with my family I'm drooling right now
about 40 family members digitally the
food in my house was very real as you
can see enjoy that it looks gorgeous so
let me talk about something that
actually is quite challenging and I that
I want to bring in a team sha he is a
medical student in he's in Pakistan and
in Pakistan
the mosque will be staying open and
cutting try to explain to us why that is
what it is about Pakistan's culture
we're family so fiercely and to
governor's he's so fiercely cherished
that people would perhaps risk their own
health and go to mosque Joseph I'm
wondering that the headlines from
Pakistan are incredible considering that
so many of us are practicing social
distance at least physical distance
whatever faith that we're in will you
make of moss in Pakistan staying open at
this time any one country I don't think
this is necessarily a responsible move
at this time one of the things that many
people have not really understood is
what is the actual or not that is the
transmitted ability factor of Rome virus
and and that's been debated and people
have said oh it's a it's a you know some
kind of scheme to get people out of the
mosques and I'm afraid that some of that
type of attitude has played into these
decisions and this is something where it
should be left to the medical experts
and the Muftis and Willem at the
scholars they need to say that this is
an area where we need to abdicate to
those who have better knowledge of how
such situations should be handled how
much guidance is how much guidance have
there been a Robina for Muslims around
the world about how you should observe
this unique Ramadan where you can't get
together as you would normally do you
can't have fellowship as you normally
have it what guidance is there we've had
the Muslim Council of Britain also issue
statement saying that mosque should be
closed and that government should not
happen and I think that is absolutely
right the government has also been
proactive as is our Council and across
the political parties as well there is
one aspect that we should also talk
about which is guidance for NHS Muslim
workers National Health Service and
people who work
in hospitals who are keeping fast so I
had a question from one of the entities
that I support Daisy who flower who I I
mean I work for the different number
politicians from the Liberal Democrats
but what she asked me and it was very
pertinent is what should I be giving the
advice or the information about Muslims
who are working in hospital settings so
the Muslim board of imams and scholars
have given direct information but whilst
they can give guidance the ultimate
decision has to be the health
professional who is working in that
setting so that it doesn't impact on the
patient protects themselves and it
doesn't add pressure on the NHS so there
is guidance out there but it's about
sharing protocols and sharing good
practices yes I want to share this tweet
with you it comes from Nigeria and Yusef
talks about villages and communities in
Nigeria they can't do digital Iftars
like they can't jump on zoom and he
talks about the options that are left
are sponsored programs from local radio
stations so if you don't have broadband
internet and a connection that's almost
as good as yours Joseph if you can't
connect it that way how else can you
connect I think I've seen that people
have been getting super creative and and
connecting in ways that are beyond the
internet I'm talking to a few people who
said that they wanted to go outside and
reconnect with nature right because this
is something that's also emphasized in
the faith I'm talking about connecting
with the immediate family members in
your home right you don't necessarily
have to go so far and wide and I think
we're seeing creativity in terms of how
are we practicing traditional elements
of the faith and I think a lot of people
are tapping into that now and Joseph I'm
sure you know better than me in terms of
the practice of seclusion right and
meditation or big practices dating back
to the prophets and there's something
that is celebrated and Ramadan and so I
think that it's probably something else
a lot of Muslims are practicing this
this month Joseph
thoughts on that one yes this is
actually a very important point thank
you for bringing it up yeah the
opportunity is when we talk about
connecting the most important connection
that you make with in Ramadan is the
connection with God and with the Quran
and all of the other connections that we
make should be viewed as secondary to
that and at times we get distracted by
the social dimensions of Ramadan from
focusing upon its alternate purpose
which is that connection with allah
subhanaw taala with God with the Quran
and through that a cleansing of
ourselves and the prophet's custom was
in the last days last 10 days of Ramadan
to go into a a solution in Ithaca and to
withdraw from society and insha'Allah
perhaps that will be something that more
people will be inclined to do in these
last in these last 10 days because
that's where the true spirit of Ramadan
is is to be found and that's even in the
Quran and when it talks about Ramadan
it's it doesn't say chef or song it's
utter crap it's it's Ramadan in which
the Quran was made to descend and the
purpose of fasting is almost opening
yourself up so that you have a space for
the word of God to be instilled within
you and thus make that connection while
you've cut off all of these connections
from the rest of the world I'm just
looking at something that we share with
our audience our online audience and we
asked her if we had any essential
workers who were out there who were also
observing Ramadan fire fighter good
handle fire fighter as a Muslim
firefighter and paramedic I've adjusted
not only by wearing PPE personal
protective equipment on every call but
also praying more at the fire station
especially after breaking my fast
Robina in London and in the UK this
whole idea of observing Ramadan when it
is so difficult and so challenging for
health workers right now and stressful
and then on top of that
to be in the holy month of Ramadan can
you give us an example of what that may
be like well where I live
the hospital London Hospital is just up
the road from me so I often speak to
some of the health workers and staff and
some of them are my constituents and
when you wear protective personal
protective equipment
it becomes very hot and it becomes very
difficult
hence the person who is in that
situation must make the decision
themselves as to what they can whether
or not they can fast but it obviously
it's obligation that if you break it
fast and you don't keep that fast
you must make sure that you keep that
fast at a later date so hence ships the
ships that they do the people that they
have around them supporting them is
fundamental but most important
fundamental is making sure that you
yourself are safe making sure the people
that you care for are safe and making
sure the environments the money many of
them could be working in icy units
that's that pressure within that unit is
unity so if they feel that they cannot
keep it it is their decision and they
are more than you want to make that
decision wait I want to bring you in
here because you've been working on a
number of stories where you're finding
Islamophobia are rising Islamophobia
online because it is the month of
Ramadan for instance this headline here
from one of your stories
anti Muslim propaganda is seeping into
online discourse about the coronavirus
can you give us an example absolutely
and I think the important thing to note
here is that unfortunately anti-muslim
rhetoric it's not only global but it's
been prevalent for a very long time and
so when the pandemic Hey it really was a
matter of taking advantage of people's
vulnerabilities of their fears of their
very valid concerns and then using that
to promote toxic disinformation
misinformation about the Muslim
community and it was a trend that I've
seen in many places and in different
parts of the world but the three that
I've highlighted in that report was the
UK the US and in India
and in the UK in the u.s. we primarily
saw the use of old footage right of say
last year's Ramadan oven Ramadan
beforehand and that being circulated on
far-right websites and and by people who
have a history of promoting anti-muslim
rhetoric and saying look at these
Muslims who are not it social distancing
they're still going to their mosques
they're still gathering etc and not only
is that false because again we're using
old image here but there's a message
that wants to vilify and demonize the
Muslims which is ironic of like Ruby and
I said because so many of them are on
the front minds
our essential workers are out there
providing the most utmost care and we're
seeing that here in the US as well we've
had another challenging point in the US
where the president Donald Trump
retweeted a tweet talking about a
disparity between the churches and the
mosques and wondering if authorities
were going to crack down on the mosques
and people gathering in the mosque was
which is again a false information
because the mosque has been closed it's
not like they were planning to open for
tomorrow and they were closed from the
first local and state and federal
discretion where gatherings were
apparent it's been over a month and in
India it's probably the worst case of
Islamophobia we've seen like you said
the mosques have chosen to stay open
phenomenon and before that you had a
small missionary group who were still
the Hemans about going out and gathering
and and therefore a number of cases have
spread because of this missionary group
and Muslims faced the consequences
you had fruit sellers who were banned
you had a Muslim man who died by suicide
because he was vilified for being
associated with this group and so the
impacts of this propaganda is it's quite
real yeah I mean we also need to when we
put this all in the context of
coronavirus that that originated in
China one of the things that the whole
of the spread of coronavirus has done
has caused everyone to look away from
what's happening to the weaker Muslims
and and that has been an absolute
humanitarian crisis and the Chinese have
just stepped up their persecution of the
we are Muslims and it's
I think that Muslims need to take into
consideration if they're worried about
being in lockdown during Muslims because
these are people in so many parts of the
world that have it far worse than those
of us who are able to participate in
this conversation both right here now
and listen to it half I'm so glad you
put up the weak Muslims because on
YouTube audience there has been chatting
about helping the poor she lands
Jitendra says it's harder for the poor
to receive if times are cut during this
month with a lockdown curfews and social
distances distancing excuse me it's
harder for them generally this whole
idea about how are you able to fulfill
your charitable deeds during Ramadan if
you can't go out and make meals for
people who are less fortunate than
yourselves
Robina how are you able to do that well
I'm at the beginning that we've been
involved with different community
organizations and the most important
aspect with this pandemic and the
started on a Barton is that many
charities missing random charities have
already begun to make sure that they are
creating the facilities to give out and
distribute meals and imperishable groups
as well to people particularly those
were very elderly particularly those who
are vulnerable know the people the
families were often very isolated
because they are in isolation
due to that that they may have people
who have got contracted at Kobey's 19
and until that I have to give a great
deal of tribute to the people who are
taking up the caring up the funerals and
various during that time I see how
Kimani care thank you for being on
YouTube with us says for those who don't
have anything to eat
Ramadan teaches us to care remember the
poor and weak people wherever you are
which really segues beautifully into
Saeed Jaffrey and he is at Pakistan
Politico and he said this time this very
unusual Ramadan reminds us that we
should be doing charitable deeds as
Muslims during this holy month so I'm
just thinking here
Joseph about the purity perhaps of a
very different kind of Ramadan where
you're not working out how many dinners
can I go to how many if does can I go to
you what are you going tonight well you
don't have that opportunity to meet up
with your friends and your family how is
this perhaps enhancing your favors a
Muslim Joseph the way in which in which
I'm sorry for that for me as a Muslim I
would say that one of the most important
things is that really one of the main
things that you also have in Ramadan but
a lot of people go to the mosques for is
it is learning is knowledge and there's
actually been a real proliferation of
people starting podcasts and other
things on on YouTube and other places to
help fill that void it's almost too much
in fact sometimes there's so many things
that I'd like to do I could fill my
whole day with them but this is
something that I think might actually be
a great opportunity for a lot of people
and find ways to connect with other
communities but I hope that they don't
take place of what happens in in the
mosque and again that aspect of not
being able to do charity in person is
very difficult but again a lot of
opportunities have opened up such as
launch good it's doing a good job of
addressing a lot of that and giving us
opportunities to practice it and and
Shalala when we are able to go back and
meet in person people will be able and
do these things more indirect giving in
the way that is our custom as Muslims
mm-hmm remain aware right at the very
beginning of Ramadan but for you how has
it been so far this very briefly to wrap
us up I have to say I do miss my
caffeine but I'm blessed to have a home
I'm blessed to be surrounded by family
I'm not alone and I'm looking forward to
making the most out of this month and
listening to what my fellow Muslims are
doing as well and two comments from
Twitter too
different comments from Twitter we have
bar JAMA she a spiritual uplift will be
many more because there won't be chance
for public lectures and other essential
gatherings and then accentuating the
positive Fulani says I am feeling
optimistic many of the early Muslims
themselves may have fasted in seclusion
we believe the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him receive revelation in seclusion
let me leave you with a delightful
picture it is a picture of the delicious
iftar dinner that Robina shared with her
family digitally so I'm gonna do that
just the same to you you can celebrate
over that and I all I'm going to say is
thank you so much
gues for being with us during this
Ramadan I know that it is not the
easiest thing to talk for half an hour
when you are fasting but we really do
appreciate you Robina role waiter Joseph
thank you very much indeed
and thank you to youtube for your
putting all your comments into a show
and if you are marking Ramadan Ramadan
Mubarak that's all for today's the
stream Home Edition see you next time
thanks for watching